also of your Jake Paul's team you're  sitting around let's say today you're  sitting around with your marketing team  who are clearly Geniuses and nobody does  a better promo and fighting you're  sitting around and they go what about  the Ben asking fight if I was probably  see my risk my hand go pros and cons  uh we kind of put up a fight but we're  probably gonna lose right and we  starched them  you know we start them we can't get  better than that so there's only  downside to this fight with him against  Ben Benny just a wrestler  you know he's the wrestler the worst  matchup for impossible give him another  Striker  don't give him a guy who can just  doesn't strike who just wants to grab us  the nightmare for Jake  there's no upside to it and I love Ben I  hope he gets a fight and gets paid but  he would absolutely Molly [ __ ] him an MMA